The joe rogan experience.
Like I saw a book of Mormon.
That was the last time I went to a play.
Unless it was like,
for what?
You see Hamilton,
one of my kids look at me.
Yeah,
I don't want to.
You think you're cultured,
man,
you're interested in all things.
I got shit to do,
man.
Whatever that hour is,
I got shit to do.
I literally know nothing about Hamilton.
I'm just joking.
You know?
It's funny because I went into it like,
what's it?
What's the crazy about,
you know,
I'm like,
this is going to be so overrated.
And then I watched,
I was like,
oh,
that was really good.
Yeah,
it was really good.
I love the pills.
Aren't forms exist,
you know,
love Broadway plays.
I'm not that big,
but I thought a book of Mormon,
I actually saw it twice.
I loved that and I thought it was,
I,
you know,
it's funny.
It's something could be,
yeah,
it was June.
Fuck those dudes.
By the way,
Matt and tray,
they're on another planet like they're fine somewhere else.
No movie.
I watched that look talking about like movies that people don't talk about
enough.
That's so fucking perfect.
Team America.
Oh my God.
That movie is like flawless.
It's one of the best movies ever for comedy.
But yeah,
it's,
you can't even believe what they accomplished in that movie.
Like they haven't seen the full uncut scenes,
the way they had sex and dropped blogs on each other.
A pistol at each other's.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And uh,
the way they start the movie,
they told him that I saw the interview,
they told a story about the opening scene of the movie.
It's a really shitty Mary in it and then it widens out and it's a marrying it in
France using a marionette
opening scene.
So he said,
they said when they fucking screened it for the studio,
that's why they did that.
It was like a really shitty looking and you heard all the executives like,
what the fuck did we paid spend all this money on?
You know,
it just reveals how there's this sense of the full unedited sex version.
They did this like way over the top and pull stuff back.
Yeah,
it's really fun.
Yeah.
They just decided to do it this way so that they,
so they would have stuff to edit out for the DVD.
This is fucking crazy.
Oh my God.
And I think apparently they,
um,
they're doing everything my ass.
Yeah.
And they did this so that they could have like,
well,
you gotta give us some of it,
you know,
give us a little,
we'll go,
they went so far over the line.
It's this every position,
everything.
They went so far,
so fucking crazy.
Like he's peeing on her
all over her face or open on and she drops a lot.
Oh my God,
look at this.
And then they just keep going.
Oh my God.
It's so stupid.
I mean it just goes on forever.
Yeah.
But they did that so that they would have room for negotiation.
That's how they worked.
Yeah.
They,
uh,
those guys who are just geniuses,
man.
And that movies,
like the whole concept of they need an actor.
Yes.
How Important Act are and how bad is acting isn't scary.
Or an ace is fucking shitty.
Make the vibe darker,
darker,
darker.
And it's the Star Wars Cantina scene.
They're like,
we're going to Trans Morga Phi you,
which has more for you.
And then like all that stuff happens to his face.
It's like 20 minutes of like,
like they make it like it's face off and then they just hit and it just glued
some fucking hair to his face.
It's so fun.
Yeah,
there it is.
It's hilarious.
They're paint them a little brown.
Gee,
come on Gary.
Act your way in.
You know
we need a top gun actor.
That's what he says.
He goes,
you're a top gun actor.
It's too bad.
This took so long to make,
cause he doesn't want to make another one.
One was broke.
Damn Dude.
Like you're just fucking,
I can only imagine how much time I must take.
This is so painstaking.
Painstaking.
I mean are they moving each piece as it's happening and then filming it and
doing it over and over and over.
You and multiple camera angles.
Multiple this shot at like a movie.
That's why it's so good.
I need to watch it again.
Forgetting this scene.
I'll tell you this is him and then it,
then it's basically the star wars Cantina when he walks in and you know,
and uh,
hold on to that yet.
It's really funny,
but it is a movie that you could come home at like two in the morning and just
so like,
oh,
I want to like kill an hour,
smoke some weed and just throw it on like at any seen it stopped at,
don't forget about the fucking south park movie.
Yes.
Your brush South Park movie where I don't know that they want to say gay with
the devil.
Devil.
Yeah,
I remember that.
The devil stick out and his Dick.
Fuck yeah.
I don't think it well,
are you kidding me?
I have to wash it in a long time.
Guarantee that'll hold up south park is still really funny.
It's still hilarious.
Yeah.
It's really funny.
I mean when it comes to overall content,
one of the funniest shows if not the funniest of all time dude,
they turned symptoms them
people love,
but it can rip on the family guy I port,
they remember the world war,
they went into the writers room in the family guy and it was two manatees in the
tank.
And what if they drop a ball and I like drop a ball at a thing and then it just
a joke comes out.
So it's like old TV show reference,
you know?
That's hilarious.
They just broke his formula down.
Yeah.
It's funny though.
It's fucking hilarious.
I think.
I think Seth Macfarlane Fun.
Like I thought that was ted movies are really funny.
I didn't see them.
Yeah,
I still haven't seen or heard.
They're hilarious.
They're,
they're not like flawless movies,
but they're funny.
Like there's,
there's a couple of scenes in them that are like so funny that the whole movie
goes up like 10 points because there's a few scenes in there.
Like there's a scene where uh,
uh,
or Ted's telling them about the weedy bought it.
He was like,
and it's like,
I forget the exact dialogue,
but it's like a,
he's like,
yeah,
it's called like,
uh,
he's like,
I got some weed.
It's called like,
kill me now,
please.
You know?
And he's like,
why don't you get that?
He's like,
well,
the only other options,
but please make it,
stop.
Make it stop.
Like he's navy in the weeds and they're all like this,
like paranoia fueled.
We'd tape.
It's really funny,
you know,
sort of like maybe the,
uh,
the ges and the hair scene and something about Mary.
But it was so funny.
I took the whole movie.
Yeah.
And then it's like,
you remember that?
Yeah.
Cause there's other stuff that's really funny in that movie that gets lost.
Like Chris,
Chris Elliott,
having the best wife ever is really funny,
but he's still in love with Mary.
That's,
it's like a joke that kind of,
she's like,
I bake cookies.
You want a blow job?
And he's like,
still in love with another woman.
That's how amazing Mary is.
[inaudible]
yeah.